qu'on a vu ce qui s'est passé c'était il
ya neuf ans c'est comment est-ce qu'on
peut résumer l'histoire est ce
qu'aujourd'hui voilà c'est un piège vous
est recommandé un piège pas vraiment on
peut pas dire ça après c'est toujours
mieux de s'attaquer à une poule aux
oeufs d'or comme cristiano ronaldo qui
en effet dans le top 3 des joueurs les
plus payés au monde qui la méga star
mais pour autant à l'époque 2009
cristiano s'était pas de cristiano
d'aujourd'hui d'accord c'était un
cristiano qui avait pas une nora à ce
point là c'était un futur très grand
mais c'était pas l'immense star
hollywoodienne qui est là aujourd'hui
d'accord on peut se poser la question du
pourquoi ça ressort aux joues devant
après l'avant après voilà voilà
et parmi ces rochus façon il était tard
dont il est vingt trois ans qu'on peut
violer à tous tout le viol n'est pas
parce qu'ils s'engagent à denia lisait
il dit que c'est un piège pas les excuse
voilà ce qu'il est il qu'ils aient ou
pas il y avait un piège par son ancien
du real madrid madrid la juventus c'est
ça ouais c'est classé il dit que c'est
un piège qu'il est tombé dedans qu'on
veut le faire tomber juste après qu'ils
pensent que c'est un piège
non elle va jouer votez on s'est cachés
bavure ce que j'ai pas piéger voilà la
cia paca se peint pas parce que c'est un
pimpant comme quoi c'est un papa papa ça
vous devez voter tous oui pourquoi
mais pas piéger voyage non il n'est pas
parce que parce que vous l'avez vu dans
ces vidéos vous le regardez chez lui
alors il se trimballe alors il vous fait
visiter sa chambre alors c'est un
lupanar ya des migrants evam personnes
il est il est obsédée par lui même il
épie les deux parcours tout au fait
quelqu'un complètement légale au mali
mais ça va c'est c'est messi parce que
je pense qu'il s'est fait moi je pense
qu'il n'est pas piéger par ce qu'il a
fait monter une nana et puis que et puis
que ba ba du village mais guillaume
c'est pas parce que ça veut dire c'est
plus autant dire que si justement il est
comme ça il est il est lé bling bling et
tout ça si les filles viennent avec ses
les filles que vous insultez là c'est
pas lui c'est elle sorte de s'en tirer
par sa une d'hier c'est marrant noter
que toutes les filles
bon il est benoit je m'envoie toutes les
filles pensent qu'il est piégé et les
garçons à versailles avait aussi il
faudra vous cherchez un peu sébastien
alors justement parce qu'il a démenti ce
serait qu'on en parle avec avec
sébastien il a démenti lundi je dément
vigoureusement les accusations qui me
visent le viol est un crime abominable
qui va à l'encontre de tout ce que je
suis de ceux que je crois merci service
de com
il va pas dire linverse je refuse de
nourrir ce cirque médiatique monté par
des gens ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya
eu un accord qui a été avec elle et
contre ça il est obligé aujourd'hui de
dire qui il a été piégé en effet parce
que il a versé plus de 300000 euros
del
le lendemain en fait puisque tout de
suite elle a été à la police de las
vegas s'est passé là-bas à la porter
plainte et se sont arrangés de cette
façon tu te tais 300000 euros 300
millions que le problème c'est que si
elle n'était pas un si elle ne s'était
pas lui il pourrait avoir perpétuité
là-bas à las vegas il ne rigole pas avec
le viol ça peut être prison à perpétuer
avant de voir avant de voir ce qu'ils
risquent justement pour l'avenir ce
garçon ce que je crois pas c'est comment
s'il a signé avec elle une clause
exclusif à une clause de confidentialité
trois cent mille euros c'est pas rien
c'est un poster lui sur instagram 300000
euros mais pour la philo 310 euros
pourquoi est ce que nos ventes après
tout d'un coup ça ressort et pourquoi ce
qu'elle parle alors ses avocats disent
qu'il ya eu un traumatisme moral qui
s'est aggravée avec le temps elle peut
en effet trois cent mille euros
voulez vous pouvez leur brûlé assez vite
et puis ronaldo en effet à l'époque ça
va les 300000 euros
aujourd'hui ronaldo ça vaut beaucoup
plus donc ils estiment qu'ils encore un
préjudice n'a pas été levé d'accord j'ai
deux mots épreuve aujourd hui non mais
je suis assez frappé ces mecs là qui
sont très marketé entouré de toute
l'équipe de com
leur naïveté est dingue dès qu'il s'agit
d'affaires privées comme ça deux sexes
et tout c'est leur île et ça c'est pas
un pro de la savane c'est pas le premier
cas scola sexuelle footballeur même le
même ronaldo le brésilien en avaient eux
aussi
rappelez-vous la sextape de valbuena
franck ribéry et zahia c'est pas croyab
d'une hausse en sapant santé supposées
néanmoins il c'est à dire d'une grande
naïveté à côté d'un contrôle de l'image
énorme